over the past 24 hours social media a
lot of you you were blowing up with
expressions of conservative outrage over
the Democrats treatment of Attorney
General Bill Barr
I think history will judge you harshly
that conclusion is inescapable sir
that's not looked at the evidence and we
can move on you've not only put your own
credibility into question but seem to be
giving sanction to behavior through the
language you used in that press
conference you held you lied and now we
know Attorney General of the United
States is a secret trust you have
betrayed that trust of course it's all
disgusting it's incredibly nasty and
it's patently unfair but why would
anyone be shocked now given that these
same Democrats what they did last
September to another Trump pick who also
had a stellar legal career are you
willing to ask the White House to
conduct an investigation by the FBI the
FBI would gather witness statements you
have they don't I don't want to debate
with you how they do their business
she's not part of the Clinton's efforts
to get some kind of revenge she is a
woman who came here with corroborating
evidence to tell her truth is that a
question no sir it was a final statement
I was obsessed with so you are not a
ballplayer I only have 23 seconds so you
are not as sloppy drunk and so your
roommate was lying
now remember Ms blase Ford's decades-old
allegations they came to light only
after some anonymous committee Democrat
leaked her letter leading blase Ford
herself to reveal her identity to the
Washington Post well similarly on
Tuesday right before bars testimony the
Muller letter was leaked to of course
the Washington Post stay with me here
now the bottom line is when the
Democrats cannot win on the merits on
the substance what do they do they want
to end the debate go right for the
jugular
strongly believe judge Cavanaugh said
would draw from consideration and the
president should withdraw this
nomination if Cavanaugh won't do it
voluntarily I join leader
she'll mertens Chloe for judge Cavanaugh
to withdraw his name from consideration
I think the nomination should be
withdrawn of course Cavanaugh remained
defiant and he refused to back down to
those Democrats and now he has a
lifetime tenure on the Supreme Court the
Democrats crashed and burned on
Cavanaugh but not only did their stunts
flop their stunts actors were actually
frauds and criminals a lot of this would
be substantiated if there was an
investigation which is what we want
we're not we are not laying out all of
the facts and all the evidence right now
that's not our obligation Committee
Chairman Chuck Grassley preferred
avenatti and Sweatt Nick last week to
the Justice Department for criminal
investigation if convicted of the 36
crimes alleged in the indictment Mr
avenatti would face a statutory maximum
sentence of 333 years in federal prison
avenatti was practically co-hosting
shows on CNN wasn't he but seven months
later here we are
and Democrats facing another brilliant
legal mind with impeccable credentials
they went back to the prop closet once
again chicken bar should have shown up
today and answered questions he was
afraid of Barry Burke he was afraid of
Norm Ison a tourney general who's picked
for his legal acumen and his abilities
would not be fearful of any other
attorneys questioning him for 30 minutes
does he sleep with that chicken I didn't
know it was pronounced acumen I guess
I'm wrong well the real chickens are the
Democrats who are too afraid to admit
that they got it all wrong on Russian
collusion and you know what else they're
too afraid to actually advance an agenda
to defend whatever policies they they
want it forward now in the midst of a
roaring Trump economy that's actually
hard stuff so what do they do they just
revert to their same old sleazy tactics
which we have exposed by the way and
documented for all of you
you know no with no glee but we've had
to document it because it's really
important night after night week after
week on this show and just like with
Kavanagh they are now calling for
someone else's head on a platter
I think that Attorney General William
bar or to recognize that he has an
obligation to resign he's burned through
any credibility he had in that role and
he should resign I think he should
resign and I think that he has made it
very clear that one he hasn't he is not
able to perform his duties remember by
the way that both Kavanagh and bar are
Bush Republicans so when you think it's
just all about Trump so anyone who's
connected to this administration this is
always shifts around ISM if you have an
RFT name they're gonna go after you but
my prediction the more Barr learns about
who and what we're behind the 2016
efforts to smear Trump is some type of
Russian collaborator the nastier and
more desperate the Democrats attacks on
bar will become I don't want to be too
specific I talked to to my car which a
few weeks ago about it and it's focused
on the FISA the basis for the FISA and
the handling of the FISA applications
but by necessity it looks back a little
bit earlier than that there must be a
lot of Obama Democrats in and out of the
deep state who are sweating now they
need bars reputation to be tarnished
that way whatever bar ultimately
concludes about the Obama DOJ can this
be written off as some mere piece of pro
Trump propaganda they have to do that
now it's what this is all about
now if Hillary and company had maybe
spent more time trying to out debate
Trump on the big issues of the day
rather than funding phony dossiers
paying all that money to Fusion GPS
maybe she would have fared better in the
last election I don't know and if
Democrats today focused more on
improving the lives of everyday
Americans instead of acting out their
silly scenes and like a Kill Bill sequel
maybe they would have more to show for
their first hundred days of house rule
than just ridiculous subpoenas
character assassination I'm betting
tonight that Americans prefer substance
and poised over stunts and noise any day
and that's the angle